all within reach
and the question today is this
can we summon the collective will to
deliver them
I believe we can
when we began our cop presidency just
one third of the global economy was
signed up to Net Zero today it is 90
percent
and for our part the UK which was the
first major economy in the world to
legislate for Net Zero will fulfill our
ambitious commitment to reduce emissions
by at least 68 by 2030.
and because there is no solution to
climate change without protecting and
restoring nature
in Glasgow more than 140 countries which
are home to over 90 percent of the
world's forests
made a historic promise to Halt and
reverse Forest loss and land degradation
by the end of this decade
and just this afternoon I co-hosted the
first meeting of the forests and climate
leaders partnership to ensure this is
delivered
Central to all our efforts is honoring
our promises on climate Finance I know
that for many finances are tough right
now
the pandemic all but broke the global
economy
and before coming here today I spent
last week working on the difficult
decisions needed to ensure confidence
and economic stability in my own country
but I can tell you today that the United
Kingdom is delivering on our commitment
of 11.6 billion pounds
and as part of this we will now triple
our funding on adaptation to 1.5 billion
pounds by 2025.
let me tell you why
first I profoundly believe it is the
right thing to do
listen to prime minister Motley of
Barbados as she describes the
existential threat posed by the ravages
of climate change
or look at the devastating floods in
Pakistan
where the area underwater is the same
size as the entire United Kingdom
when you see 33 million people displaced
with disease rice and spreading through
the water
you know it is morally right to honor
our promises
but it is also economically right too
climate security goes hand in hand with
energy security
Putin's aborrunt war in Ukraine and
Rising Energy prices across the world
are not a reason to go slow on climate
change
they are a reason to act faster
because diversifying our energy supplies
by investing in Renewables is precisely
the way to ensure ourselves against the
risks of energy dependency
it is also a fantastic source of new
jobs and growth
in Glasgow we began an approach globally
using Aid funding to unlock billions of
pounds of private Finance for the
development of new green infrastructure
so instead of developing countries being
unfairly burdened with the carbon debt
of richer Nations and somehow expected
to forego that same path to growth
we are helping those countries deliver
their own fast track to clean growth and
the UK is making further commitments to
support this today including by
investing 65 million pounds in a range
of green investment projects in Kenya
and in Egypt
I'd like to pay tribute to president
CeCe for his leadership in bringing us
all together
and to thank the UK's president of cop26
alok Sharma for his inspiring work to
deliver on the Paris agreement and
Glasgow climate Pact
by honoring the promises we made in
Glasgow and by directing public and
private Finance towards the protection
of our planet
we can turn our struggle against climate
change into a global mission for new
jobs and clean growth
and we can bequeath our children A
Greener planet and a more prosperous
future
that's a legacy we could be proud of
so as we come together once again in
common cause today
there really is room for hope
together
let us fulfill it thank you
thank you your Excellency there we are
Rishi sunak speaking in Sharma Sheikh in
a uh well a fairly uh short speech he
said that um we need to help countries
Fast Track uh fast track to clean a
growth he also spoke about Pakistan and
the awful floods in Pakistan and he said
when you see 33 million people displaced
in Pakistan you know it is morally right
to honor our promises but as I say a
very short speech from Rishi sunac in
charm or Shake let's go to Skies Ashner
huronag who was uh watching that so
Ashner what did you make of that
going to be short and sweet Mark I think
he perhaps said the right things but
much of this we know was about symbolism
it was about prime minister Rishi sunak
being at cop27
um after initially saying he wasn't
going to be there in terms of funding
pledges and Promises the UK's tripling
funding for climate adaptation for from
500 million pounds he said to 1.5
billion pounds we understand that's
going to happen up up to 2025. he also
said he was he confirmed that there
would be a 65 million pound fund that
essentially supports Forest communities
you're right he did mention the
devastation that we have seen in
Pakistan perhaps that is the most
notable climate disaster that we've seen
and covered here on Sky News some 40
billion pounds worth of damage done to
communities over there millions of
people displaced and taking the lives of
1 700 people over the summer but no
mention in that short speech from the
Prime Minister about what pledges
perhaps there might be towards helping
those developing countries who are
currently facing the impact of climate
change in the here and now that is what
many of those countries and Nations that
are taking part in this fortnightly
Summit will be wanting to hear from
richer Nations like the UK something
called the loss and damage fund no
mention of that but right in a way that
he did address the conference just a
very very short speech yep Ashner thank
you very much indeed and indeed uh no
word there from Rishi sunak on this
whole issue of reparations but he did
say that climate security
goes hand in hand with energy security
that's Rishi sunac tonight in charmel
Sheikh in Egypt we'll have much more on
that at the top of the hour
[Music]